[Musique]
paris la culture maintenant bon sens
mais c'est pas encore avoué des gens
fous j'ai dit que j'étais fan alors pour
vous en arrivez aux manoeuvres
jean françois bizot il semble donc que
l'équipe d'actuels l'équipe de ce
mensuel et qui a s'est arrêtée de
paraître il ya deux ou trois ans
s'ennuyer un peu puisque vous avez vous
êtes pour vous avez pris vos plumes
même celles qu'on avait envie de
travailler ensemble mais pour commencer
je voudrais quand même toujours jeu ça
fait un moment que j'essaie de casey mon
ouvrage de politique fiction que nous
avons jetés parce que nous avions
commencé stallman a dont vous avez parlé
si vous voulez pour faire un peu la
nausée sont 18 et c'est pour ça que
j'aime la forme de petits cadeaux à mes
amis parce que je pensais qu'il fallait
rien respecté alors pour commencer
j'avais amené ce qu'on a jetée que je
vais donner à jean yanne personnes âgées
politique fiction qu'on a jetée
puisqu'il marché ne peut rien de marché
avec un archet puisqu'on était parti sur
le fait qu'ils avaient une gauche qui
était contente ça plus pudiques fusil ou
si la gauche n'est pas craqué je vous le
donne c'est pour noël oui j'ai dit oui
alors comme j'avais amené un certain
nombre de petits cadeaux j'aime d'amour
cabu entre les halles à l'aide du
pistolet pour se défendre
qui pourra brûlé y brûle les hommes et
brûlé 1 kg à mener pour dessus
maintenant un tout petit chameau ces
très jeunes qui sont gentils les punks
un dromadaire
j'aime les brunes chouchou un peu de
gomina pour passer sur le lourd pour que
ça glisse mieux en france voilà là il
est trop vous pouvez me dire ça aux gens
du tout un souvenir la manifestation de
klose croissant un formidable fanas de
lacrymogène qui est tombé tout près de
moi et je voudrais que vous regardez de
près monsieur vous avez vu beaucoup dans
votre vie est alors dite et la vie je
suis partisan c'est mélanger ou ne-yo
ah bah non c'était des vrais gros
matelas quant à vera pivot je marche
bien mais une chance l'honneur d'être
punk cinq minutes après
je connais quelques admirables d'une f
quant à moi j'arrête illico de pink jory
bourhis genre devient sympathique ne
sera voilà alors c'est tellement plus
simple
bon revenons à votre almanach actuel là
et le puy à vous ennuyer vous étiez on
va reprendre du service
mais qu'est ce que vous avez voulu faire
et al manara gaz
moi je suis folle mascareignes ça vous
et comment cette pointe qu'en 7 mai
maintenant un beau récital manas si vous
voulez basse et c'est donc un produit
qu'on a fait on est obligé de jeter
beaucoup de choses puisque tout changer
sans arrêt donc je c'est difficile de
s'en émeut pas parce que on pense
qu'ensuite journalistes et puis en fait
c'est jamie du journalisme puisque le
temps passe les articles se périment il
faut acheter
donc j'en ai quelques uns qui ont acheté
à jean yanne depuis la gauche a craqué
mais sinon donc on a essayé de faire un
espèce de produits littérature populaire
en fait on en avait assez de ça on n'a
pas écrit beaucoup de livres
enfin disons quand on arrêtait actuelle
c'est essentiellement pour écrire des
livres finalement c'est à dire pour
avoir une démarche individuelle et que
bon là on préférait refaire un ouvrage
collectif d'une part et c'est un truc
varié où il risque est ce que vous vous
réclamez du mouvement punk c'est à dire
que je ne réclame pas eu de mouvement
punk mais il se trouve que je connais
pas mal de punk parce que finalement
dents et lecteurs actuels il
pas mal il ya des pales de gens qui sont
assez punk et que si vous laissez cette
ça ressort essentiellement de l'ennui
qui ressentait parce qu'il faut
reconnaître que depuis ces jeunes pris
en commun
on a écrasé les anciens gauchistes
complètement pendant des années en
attendant que ça se passe c'est à dire
que l'élection ait lieu et que il
fallait surtout pas intervenir dire quoi
que ce soit pour saper l'avenir
socialiste radieux de la france et donc
on s'est tu et qu'un ce moment ça a pesé
et sur nous et sur les mecs plus jeune
et que ça produit aussi une espèce
d'esprit dérisoire et tragique ne sais
pas moi littéraire mais qui est le fun
c'est marrant parce que si vous laissez
le punk un peu le résultat de
l'étouffement des quatre dernières
années depuis à ces jo programme commun
c'est à dire du fait qu'on attendait on
attendait on attendait on se taisait
il avait repris la plupart des idées du
bushisme c'était eux qui à les appliquer
ce qui nous irait kahn est tristement
parce qu'évidemment sans qu'il en ait
pas tellement vu c'était donc eux qui
allait changer la vie en ne changeant
absolument pas leur vie ni leur tête ni
leur apparence physique un certain
moment ni rien je veux dire c'est pour
ça que délibérément j'avais changé de
tête au milieu de cette émission pour
montrer que finalement vous ne respectez
rien c'est le sujet de cette émission
si vous ne respectez rien mais c'est
très respectable finalement personne ne
remet en cause ne serait-ce que son
vêtement son apparence quoi que ce soit
on ne parle plus de rien je veux dire de
puissantes 8
on est tombé complètement à la trappe
sur le thème de changer la vie c'est
fini maintenant la désillusion règne on
ne croit à rien on est là à s'allonger
le masque toute la journée à dire qu'est
ce que c'est triste jean yanne
recommence à nous faire rire en faisant
un feuilleton heureusement j'ai tourné
l'autre jour le bouton j'étais content
je lui rends hommage rien que pour ça va
parler on va parler oui non mais je le
dis mais sinon mêlant sinon c'est si
j'en sais vraiment pas alors le le punk
finalement c'est ça ça veut dire ça
c'est tout ça veut dire tout d'un coup
c'est pour ça que nenni ce n'est le nist
de toujours quand le gauchisme a disparu
il n'y a plus de croyance ni d'espoir un
certain nombre de gens nous ont dit il
ne faut rien espérer
où nous on dit il n'ya que la virilité
macho qui compte
il faut aller cogner bon allez on va
cogner au polisario il y en a qui disent
d'autres idiomes égale à 10 mais oui bon
qui disent si vous voulez on a raconté
sur la bande à baader des des choses qui
sont d'un excès absolument scandaleux
quand je pense que la même semaine où
bader été tués on se trouvait avec 120
morts dans une raffinerie ou je sais pas
quoi lui acte il qu'elles ont été
massacrés par la police et qui ont fait
deux lignes dans les journaux je veux
dire moi je peux pas c'est une émission
drôle donc j'arrête
mais il n'empêche que sa joie aux gens
alors je percevais qui n'entrent dans
aucune de vos catégories non moi je vais
vous le dire même une chose il vaut
mieux hier dans les miennes moi il me
consterne parce qu'il parle de 68 comme
certains que je prépare ce de 14,9 en
mer ben oui mais vous êtes un vieux
crois mais j'en ai rien à [ __ ] papin
vous avez vous dit que vous avez l'air
[Musique]
c'est navrant de voir vous en êtes
encore avec vous à quoi vous êtes en 61
avant la création de l observateur alors
excusez-moi mais oui mais bisous vous
êtes intéressé ponsable d un peu
responsable de tout de ce que tu de ce
dont tu te plains pourquoi avoir arrêté
arrêté pac actuelle en pleine en pleine
gloire
c'est plus rien à dire non mais rien à
dire tu as des choses à dire on a
pourquoi tu as arrêté et j'ai recommencé
déjà commencé non mais pourquoi toujours
la gauche la droite yahia aucun nouveau
joueur à la gauche et la droite la
gauche je veux l'armée la droite veut
l'armée moi je comprends pas précise que
tu veux dire je veux dire par l'amp le
mans parlons alors il ya six grands
chapitres les deux moyens grands
chapitres le ya le pouvoir il ya la tête
et il ya eu le crâne pas le prince de la
tête
non il se trouve si vous voulez que ce
qu'on a voulu faire c'est on a été
frappé par le fait que dans les journaux
on avait un problème par rapport à la
façon dont les articles étaient écrits à
savoir que si vous voulez
comment dire il n'y avait plus beaucoup
de reportages d'une part dans france
soir qui était le grand journal du
reportage et qui l'est moins depuis que
lazard est mort mais enfin il faut bien
connaître
donc il ya eu beaucoup de reportages
donc on avait envie de faire du
reportage et de décrire la façon dont le
réel fonctionne c'est à dire que si on a
c'est un chapitre le pouvoir c'est aussi
pour pour raconter comment ça marche
dans le quotidien c'est à dire que il
est bien évidente le fait de raconter le
quotidien du pouvoir par exemple une
forme de littérature populaire le pose
un problème parce qu'on arrive assez
vite près de la magouille c'est à dire
qu il
il est un fait que on apprend enfin que
j'ai failli sur parti socialiste si vous
voulez c'est à ce moment là que parce
que je comprenais rien à la politique
j'avais été gauchistes des années je ne
comprenais rien à la politique d'un fait
précis intéressant parce que le
gauchisme c'était une illusion lyrique
ou un désir très profond d'intervention
sur les idées et le réel s'était lancé
de l'utopie pour que pour qu il se passe
des choses si vous l'aimez bien c'est
vraiment bon je vous explique bombe est
donc on a fait une description de tas de
petites histoires de pouvoir alors par
exemple on y trouve la liste des membres
de ce fameux club du siècle comme ça il
s'en voulait le montrer simuler ce qui
est fantastique en france alors ce qui
me fait rêver à chaque fois c'est qu'ils
se rencontrent sans arrêt mais ils
s'insultent par devant et rencontre par
derrière à part les femmes qui sont pas
dans l'association du sexe c'est sûr
qu'ils sont uniques et fait un petit
scandale qui venait de nous ont publié
les premiers souffler après une nouvelle
économistes et après il ya eu l'humanité
s'est tenue cette liste par hasard et
cette cession serait une façon très
normal le troisième mercredi de chaque
mois et réunit donc du crs et bon nombre
d'accord alors il ya les avis des
organisations contrôlée par le pc vous
donner des conseils aux squatteurs pour
rester en maintenant à ce sujet oui mais
oui mais oui vous dit ceci ne faite
jamais confiance à un type qui a plus de
30 ans oui évidemment
vous en avez plus de 34 9 33 ans de voir
la confiance nous ont fait confiance
il ya un document alors génial faut que
le 1er janvier page 140 noah si j'aime
le mieux c'est la maison de la star
la maison de la star mais en forme de
moto non mais regardez pas changer mon
terroir et java sont 43 c'est l'arbre
généalogique du gauchisme ça c'est
fabuleux
enfin remplacer rien des flèches de tout
les côtés ça se croise ar phares du
merveilleux non ce document même les
gens viennent rythmer reste difficile
d'autant que ça fait déjà pour un quart
d'heure est là non jean dutourd qu'est
ce que vous pensez la da manha actuel ça
reste ça renouvelle le genre parce que
vous avez été un lecteur des débuts de
manoeuvre moi j'étais lecteurs de
l'allemagne à hachette et je l'albane à
quel jeu les bien aimés mais je n'ai pas
trouvé tellement irrespectueux voyez
vous ah bon non j'ai trouvé des choses
qui montrent pas du tout choquée que
vous qu'en fin que je pense depuis
toujours et je me suis dit de ce fait
que c'était quelque chose de sympathique
puisque c'étaient mes idées mais ça ne
m'a pas semblé très irrespectueux vous
avez les mêmes citer tous les deux mais
j'ai trouvé non mais c'est la vieille
tentative sa non non il ya aucune
tentative non ce que j'ai à dire de cabu
je le lui dirai tout à l'heure nous
empêcher de le dire deux ans j'ai voulu
dire
mais là je suis désolé de vous dire que
vous m'avez pas choqué du tout c'est
quand même pas sa condamnation est pas
m'avoir choisie et cherchent pas du tout
vous annexe est d'ailleurs parfois
traitement je suis parfois triste quand
je vous lis parfois gay d'ailleurs j'ai
plein jour de d'opinion il n'avait je
vous dire je suis ainsi au bon beurre et
un bon livre
merci au ressenti principalement aux
talents alors quand l'allemagne actuelle
du talent dedans je trouve ça bien
il ya des pav où il ya moins de talent
c'est ça qu'ils auraient créé tout le
tout le livre sa vie n'a pas de talent
c'est moi d'ailleurs allemand oui
pourquoi avoir arrêté actuelle on arrête
actuelle on n'a plus rien à dire alors
nous à charlie hebdo on avait l'air de
guignol on continue à avoir des choses à
dire aussi que nous mais nous on a
quelque chose à dire chaque semaine et
on gueule à bas toutes les armées
[Musique]